Hey Youtubers! It's Charlie.
So the actress who plays Lyanna Stark
did this really cool interview talking about the "Tower of Joy"
So I'm gonna explain what she said and what it means
about that flashback.
Just careful for spoilers if you haven't seen season 6 yet
So the actress who played Lyanna Stark,
you might remember from "The Fall"
I actually didn't realize it was her. I've seen "The Fall"
it's an amazing series. And now that
I realize who she is on that series
it's seems so apropos
that she's Lyanna Stark. Because of the scandal
that she was caught up in Westeros with Rhaegar Targaryen
So naturally... She played a very scandalous
character on "The Fall"; very different
type of scandalous. But the way people
inside Game of Thrones, the actual characters,
talked about it in retrospect,
it was extremely scandalous that they'd
run off together. Although when most of the characters
talked about on the books and on the tv show
they make it sound like Rhaegar kidnapped her
the twist probably being that
they were in love, but Lyanna Stark
had been betrothed to Robert, Rhaegar was already married
but there wasn't a whole lot that they could do about it
so they just decided to bail; that's for future seasons to reveal
I believe there'll be more flashbacks
that will spell that out a little bit better
But the actress, whose name is Aisling,
she actually said that she did speak a sentence
when she was whispering to Ned
she was like: "I'm not sure that I can reveal it,
because I don't know which direction they are gonna take it
in future seasons, but it is an actual sentence"
So what she does say, that we do hear,
is that "Robert will kill him, you have to protect him.
He wouldn't understand"
So right now a lot of people are like:
It sounds like she's telling him who the baby's name is
Jon Snow maybe has a Targaryen name
that's really where most of the speculation is
but I think is a little bit broader than that.
I think she's explaining the whole situation to Ned,
like... this is what happened: we ran off together
this baby is ours
please protect him.
So it's not just his name that she's whispering
she's basically giving him all this exposition
probably explaining that: No, he didn't kidnapped me
we ran away together, we were in love.
But then you do hear the part when she's like:
"Robert totally will not understand,
he will kill the baby.
Please promise me Ned"
So it is totally possible that Jon Snow has a Targaryen name
but I don't think that's the only thing that's happening
when she's whispering to him.
But of course the tv show isn't gonna slap you in the face
with something that is never gonna explain.
So at some point in the future.
next season or season 8
they will finally reveal the rest of that backstory
But because season 6 was all about revealing Jon Snow's mother
I think season 7 will spell out his father a little bit more
we all know is Rhaegar Targaryen now
so we're just gonna learn a little but more about him,
probably through Bran's flashbacks.
But the other cool thing about them casting Aisling for this very specific scene
because there was other actress in another flashback
it was a much youger version of Lyanna Stark
because The tourney at Harrenhal and this event aren't too far apart in time
she could totally play Lyanna in another flashback
that is just earlier in time
when she and Rhaegar actually do meet, and then choose to run off together.
So I'm thinking The tourney at Harrenhal,
I'm thinking Knight of the Laughing Tree
but the actress was a little coy when she talked about
whether of not she was coming back.
Like... she didn't flat out said No or Yes.
So all I would say is that they would pretty much have to use her again
if they were gonna do "Tourney at Harrenhal"
and for those of you who are wondering about the time-line of Tourney at Harrenhal,
Robert's rebellion, and Jon Snow's birth,
you have to look at the books
because The Tourney at Harrenhal happened in 281AC,
Robert's rebellion ended in 283AC
and this Tower of Joy event happened right at the end of that,
so Jon Snow born somewhere around the end of 283, early 284 maybe
very fuzzy on the date
so you could just say that Jon Snow was born right at the tale end of Robert's rebellion.
you could see that it was actually even less than 3 years passed
between the Tourney at Harrenhal, Rhaegar abducting Lyanna and then Jon Snow being born.
So I'll be really curious of the way they paint Rhaegar&Lyanna's relationship early on
just because it sounds like if they only met at the Tourney at Harrenhal,
like...they would've had to had met each other before then,
otherwise is love at first sight, and then they just immmediatly rushed off
and cause this giant scandal,
which is totally possible happen,
but it sounds like the way people talk about Rhaegar,
he was a little more calculated, obsessed with a prophecy,
So maybe they met each other when they were children
and they got to know each other better as they got a little bit older.
Then you get to the Tourney at Harrenhal;
where she would have been around 15 or 16 years old at the Tourney at Harrenhal,
right about the age that Sansa would have been when she was forced to marry Ramsay
like really close, so you can see how there's a common theme
of women being married to people when they don't want to
they're kind of being passed around, so lot of the alliances were forged through marriage.
So naturally, you can see how, in a time of relative peace,
Lyanna Stark, who people say Arya is just like
You can imagine if Arya was forced to marry someone...
what she would probably do?
She would probably run off too.
You can see how if she cared about someone else
like Rhaegar Targaryen, or fell in love with him
how she would pull an Arya, and just bail.
So I'll be really interested to see how the show deals with that
like if it's in a really brief flashback that Bran sees.
Typically they like to do things visually
without explaining it, without a lot of talking.
which I think is actually a good thing,
like the way they transitioned from baby Jon Snow to adult Jon snow
to tell you who the baby is.
So we'll probably see a crown of blue roses,
but then they would also have to explain how they kind of run off together
Robert went crazy, Robert's rebellion started,
and then you could go back to the season 6 episodes
and watch how that all ended.
Let me know what you guys think about the idea, the twist of their relationship
being they were actually in love
and they ran off. Rhaegar didn't force her to run off
and have this Jon Snow prophecy baby
It sounds like the way the show is treating prophecy
as in the way lot of people talked about it
like it's a big deal,
but in reality when people are in the moment making real decisions
they don't think about prophecies at all,
is all just pure emotion
Like when Melisandre is resurrecting Jon Snow
she'd completely given up on the idea of prophecy.
She only doubled down on it and started calling him "the one who was promised"; after he was risen.
So for a long time we have been talking about how Rhaegar
was obsessed with the prophecy of "The prince that was promised"
I wouldn't be surprised if the show takes a slightly different interpretation
when we actually see him,
and it seems more like an emotional response like:
"I'm not really happy in my marriage to Elia Martell,
yes I have a family,
I'm a prince, I have obligations,
but I really love Lyanna Stark"
and then Lyanna Stark, adult Arya, being like:
"I'm not super hot in being forced into a marriage with Robert Baratheon,
when I'm in love with this other person";
so they both just collectively decided to bail,
and then over the course of that year she gets pregnant,
9 months later Robert's rebellion ends, we get Jon Snow.
So let me know if you agree in the comments
They do the Tourney at Harrenhal flashback,
because it happened less than 3 years before Jon Snow was born,
and they have to bring these actors back.
Let me know if you think they will actually spell it out pretty clearly
that they were in love and ran off together
or if they would be very ambiguous about it
That would be a little infuriating, but I can understand
that the show didn't want to over-explain things.
But of course they will eventually explain what she whispered to Ned,
I think is gonna be broader than just explaining what his Targaryen name is,
if he has one.
But when you're thinking about baby Jon Snow's real name,
or possible real Targaryen name,
just remember that babies in Westeros
typically didn't get a real name until they were 2 years old,
so that is why Ned later named the baby Jon Snow,
he probably didn't named him Jon right after he walked out of the tower.
But just as a reminder big Game of Thrones stuff happening next week.
There's gonna be a Comic-Con panel,
they're probably going to announce a few things about next season,
there might be a casting reel, so be sure to suscribe to get that video
whatever they end up doing, I will totally do a video for it.
The giveaway will be next week,
there's also a new round of the giveaway that's going on right now;
all you have to do to enter is be a suscriber and leave a comment on this video.
So what's gonna happen is I'll do a Q&A video in a couple days
and then early next week, I'll do a comic con preview.
But if there's any other Game of Thrones videos that you guys want me to do,
just let me know on the comments.
While you guys wait for me to post my next video
you can click here for the Azor Ahai video that I just did,
about Jon Snow and Daenerys, about how the show is messing with the idea of Azor Ahai.
And you can click here for my Suicide Squad, Harley Quinn trailer.
Thank you so much for watching everybody!, let's high-five, I see you guys tonight.